many years ago many five six seven eight
years ago it was obvious to me and it
was really obvious to my entire field
particle physics that the Large Hadron
Collider was finally the experiment that
could go to the energy level where we
would answer questions that we've been
basically asking our entire careers we
were in a state of affairs where the
entire population of particle physicists
were still active in the field had never
seen a discovery at this level and we
knew it was coming you could do the
calculation and and decide immediately
that somebody should make a documentary
film and the thing that is coming or was
coming was really a statement about how
much information about the universe
can we get does all the information we
want all the things we want to discover
about how things work are they
accessible is that information in a sort
of goofy way of putting it is it in our
universe some of the crazier sounding
ideas that have been coming out in the
last ten years is the idea of a
multiverse the fact that the laws of
physics themselves are not fundamental
as we measure them they're a reflection
of one possible way the physical reality
could be and the multiverse is a much
more physical example of how you could
imagine different possibilities of
nature itself could be manifest here
where we measure things in our entire
observable universe and then what's
outside of it and while that all sounds
very dramatic and exciting it is both
something that scientists can think
about in great detail and try to figure
out and sociologically it's a little bit
of a nightmare scenario which is are we
going to come to the point in this
direction where the numbers we measure
and the equations that sort of describe
as much of physics as possible were
really generated randomly that they
actually came out of a whole bath of
possible laws of physics
and the ones we measure are the ones
that generate structure in our universe
and therefore life and therefore human
beings and so we are biased by what we
measure by the fact that we're here and
we're measuring it that the universe or
part of the universe we're in has enough
structure and complexity to produce
humans or any sort of observer
whatsoever or at the very least planets
or galaxies or stars so that it was this
sort of drama the deep drama that was
actually going on in the mid 2000s when
I decided that somebody needed to record
this event and what I knew is whatever
the LHC saw or didn't see it would
inform us along those lines emotionally
it was going to be very dramatic no
matter what we didn't know we would
discover the Higgs that that would be
the thing that people sort of hung on to
we the community knew that this was so
big and this was generational that it's
going to affect everybody